alors qu'arrive 19 ans meilleur buteur
du championnat
l'une des grosses attractions et compris
en équipe de france est ce que ça va pas
un peu trop vite
est ce que vous arrivez à contrôler tout
ça moi j'arrive à contrôler les pieds
sur terre maintenant apprécier ctu à a
tout le travail que je fais depuis trois
ans avec les professionnels j'ai
beaucoup appris que ce soit avec un
entraîneur comme gérard houllier qui me
mettait un peu côté gauche côté droit ça
a permis à étoffer mon jeu maintenant
aujourd'hui jiazheng prix qu'une bonne
préparation je fais attention à tout ce
que je fais aujourd'hui voilà ça se voit
que dans les matches je me sens bien et
j'arrive à terminer les matchs en avoir
deux crampons et psychologiquement vous
êtes toujours le même n'avait pas changé
non j'ai pas sûr c'est juste un peu
grandir votre ferme et non sinon j'ai
pas changé je suis toujours le même et
voilà j'espère que ça va continuer pour
moi je sais bien mais bon je sais pas il
ya une telle sérénité on a l'impression
que vous avez déjà presque 30 ans alors
qu'en fait vous en avec 19,3 non mais
bon c'est je suis à lyon et voilà jeu
avec des joueurs
les joueurs qui sont plus âgées que moi
et c'est clair images de demander
conseil
que ce soit du niño coupé beau vous et
moi ma force c'est que j'ai confiance en
moi et voilà c'est ça le démontrent sur
le terrain que j'ai confiance en moi et
vous êtes bien bien entouré aussi je
crois que la famille c'est important les
cueilleurs il ya ma famille mes mais
quelques amis ces mêmes qu'avant ces
mêmes si elles mêmes qu'avant et il ya
aussi mon agent qui me donne de bons
conseils et voilà tout va bien pour moi
et copains aller parce que vous êtes du
coin vous êtes vous êtes n'est pas loin
d'ici c'est ça je n'ai à lyon 2e moi je
suis de d'un quartier qui s'appelle bon
terrain et vous calcule encore les potes
là parce que bah ouais c'est clair
maintenant on dit plus voilà c'est les
hommes à dire voilà c'est un peu la star
du quartier dont j'aime bien moi ça me
fait plaisir que d'encore parler avec
eux de m'arrêter de leur donner des
conseils sur n'importe quoi comme ça
montre que j'ai pas changé envers eux
alors calme vers quoi maintenant porter
l'effort qu'est ce que je pouvais encore
améliorer dans votre jeu
tout n'est pas encore parfait quand même
leur moi je diffuse partout maintenant
avec les années je vais prendre de plus
de maturité je pense même si je suis
j'en ai je vais essayer d'aller au plus
grand des sommets quoi alors les sommets
d'il ya déjà 2 2 qui se profile
glasgow rangers ce mardi là faudra pas
se rater
et puis bordeaux après ça s'est il va
falloir enchaîner en une grosse semaine
notre nom glasgow il faut il faut il
faut qu'on gagne absolument ce match
pour revenir dans ce groupe de ligue des
champions et on va tout faire pour
gagner après un match encore pour pour
rester en haut du tableau contre une
bonne équipe de bordeaux et je pense que
ça va être un gros match aussi grand
merci bon courage neuf buts au compteur
c'est karim benzema est la tête bien
pleine et bien fait
[Musique]